bonsoir à vous deux pour en savoir bien
ça va bien je vous renvoie la question à
vous de ce goût du jour d'abord parce
que là la meilleure des nouvelles c'est
la réouverture des cinémas même temps le
couvre-feu reste en place comment vous
réagissez un côté on va prendre les
bonnes nouvelles parce qu'il n'a pas eu
beaucoup donc on va les prendre à bras
ouverts quand ça vient on couvre feu je
pense qu'on va quand même devoir avait à
boire une discussion avec monsieur
legault il va falloir qu'on comprenne
que durant la relâche scolaire c'est
parfait on est ouverts en matinée donc
on peut desservir la clientèle mais
arrivé durant la semaine normale hors de
la relâche scolaire comme on dirait le
monde son travail et les enfants sont à
l'école dont durant le jour on est
ouvert pour qui et faudrait moi je vous
dis qu'il faudrait bouger le couvre-feu
en navarre et demi commence en avant
j'ai au moins ça nous donnerait une
séance de 7 heures et tous les jours on
apprenait vendredi samedi dimanche
parfait ça pourrait effectivement faire
partie des annonces éventuelle
réouverture des salles de cinéma
lorraine pintal n'est pas des salles de
théâtre est ce que vous comprenez ça non
je dois dire que c'est le silence aussi
qui m'inquiète alors bien sûr je suis
ravi de monsieur guzzo de la réouverture
des salles de cinéma ça fait partie des
déconfinement que l'on souhaite mais je
trouve une équitable la décision de ne
pas ouvrir dans cette foulée les salles
de théâtre
quelle différence y at-il tant entre une
salle de théâtre et une salle de cinéma
alors que nous appliquons toutes les
mesures sanitaires comme vous le faites
d'ailleurs et que les corridors
sanitaires sont très bien éduqué pour le
public qui vient voir un spectacle est
toujours avec le masque c'est ce qu'on
préconise alors j'arrive pas à
comprendre la cohérence de cette
décision et ce qui m'inquiète pour même
pour les salles de cinéma c'est est ce
que c'est une mesure qui va s'appliquer
uniquement pendant la semaine du congé
scolaire
qu'est ce qui va se passer après pour le
couvre-feu bien sûr que pour nous aussi
c'est un empêchement parce que 20 heures
nous c'est l'isr presque de spectacle
maintenant on peut bouger des horaires
sa sphère professionnelle mais ça se
fait monsieur melon je suis content
andré nous bien sûr me fait ça fait
qu'on va revenir à la charge pour voir à
ce que les salles de théâtre ouvre le
plus tôt possible
monsieur legault a dit moi pour moi
c'est pour de bon monsieur arruda a dit
ensuite bien il va falloir réévaluer est
ce que monsieur guzzo vous entendez
qu'il est possible qu'on rouvre mais
qu'on referme quelque part au mois de
mars
surtout s'il y a des variables c'est si
la crise reprend d'ampleur écoutez moi
j'ai posé la question vidéos sms et la
réponse était que kan était au vert pour
de bon maintenant je pense qu'il faut
être raisonnable et froid être logique
c'est sûr que le pignon de rester
ouverts ou de rester fermés doit quand
même être relié à la santé publique et
on doit s'attarder à ça c'est sûr que si
on revient à 3 4 5 10 mille copies on
commence à avoir une perte de contrôle
le jeu pourrait quand même comprendre ça
être content je pourrais comprendre le
pourquoi qu'on ferme les établissements
une autre fois mais vous n'êtes pas les
seuls à avoir compris un certain point
qu'est ce que c'est pour une semaine au
foot plusieurs semaines donc j'ai posé
la question oui j'ai eu la réponse avant
même qu'elle pourrait ministre le 10 ans
en ondes que c'était pour de bon mais
c'est toujours tout qui skie pour de bon
et quand même content j'allais là les
recommandations de la santé publique
là dans la bonne solution c'est pour de
bon jusqu'à preuve du contraire
monsieur legault monsieur legault a
parlé de vous monsieur guzzo emprunter à
10 minutes et il a fait mention des
salles de spectacles nous fait entendre
l'extrait puis je faire réagir ensuite
donc ont eu des discussions avec mon
cher ami monsieur guzzo puis tous ceux
qui ont des salles de cinéma on pense
que ça va être possible pour le 26
février d'en voir des films d'arrow des
productions dans les salles de spectacle
lundi ce qui vendredi de la semaine
prochaine
c'est pas très réaliste puis je pense
qu'on peut occuper
plus d'enfants avec des cinémas
achetez-vous ce discours là madame
pintal d'abord oui c'est sûr qu'on a
besoin d'un certain temps pour que la
majorité des théâtres soit prêt à
présenter des spectacles
nous on peut dire qu'on est prêt à
présenter des spectacles alors ces trois
semaines tant mieux mais on peut réagir
aussi très rapidement si on veut
desservir l'auditoire des enfants ça se
justifie très bien mais il ya des
maisons théâtre ici à idées il ya des
salles de théâtre quand même qu'ils se
préoccupent de l'enfance mais aussi de
la santé mentale des adultes alors les
adultes aussi peuvent y trouver leur
compte
alors moi je vois pas encore pourquoi il
faut pénaliser les salles de théâtre par
rapport aux salles de cinéma est par
contre il ya la question de la jauge qui
est très important pour nous l'aja
l'orge l'a dit ça parce que la
distanciation social nous aussi c'est un
frein à l'expression artistique alors on
aurait besoin d'avoir plus de détails et
on espère que l'annoncent des cinémas
est une lueur d'espoir pour les real
pour qu'on puisse ouvrir bientôt
alors monsieur legault dit mon cher ami
monsieur guzzo parce que vous avez quand
même été très critique à son endroit et
sur twitter encore il ya hier au
dimanche vous avez publié un tweet là je
pense qu'on va le voir à l'écran où vous
avez dit les coffres sont vides on est
en tutelle depuis un an basé sur des
décisions arbitraires et non
transparente
le gouvernement nous demande de leur
faire confiance mais le gouvernement n'a
pas confiance en nous expliquez-nous un
peu monsieur vous ou votre position là
dessus je prends avant je suis ni le
fait qui m'a appelé sont chers amis
c'est bien mieux sac que d'être sur son
dos donc j'ai progressé dans les styles
de monsieur le premier studio croyants
sur un compte et d'une critique qu'il
faut prendre un petit peu mais critique
comme je l' ai déjà dit en public mais
qui aux dernières élections j'ai voté
pour monsieur legault et donc je
m'attends mieux
et des fois les critiques que je fais
c'est pour soulever le fait que je crois
que ce gouvernement là peut faire mieux
et faut aussi se rappeler qu une partie
de mes critiques vient du fait que moi
j'ai accès vue aux discussions que j'ai
nombreuses discussions avec la santé
publique j'ai accès des recommandations
qui ont été faites
et des fois je trouve qu'on que du
revers de la main on met de côté ses
recommandations lors il ça risque c'est
la santé publique qui les experts donc
encore une fois je suis flatté deuxième
mention de la part du ministre mais
laisse le fait que ce qui reste comme
ils sont allez vous suivre les
suggestions du premier ministre qui vous
demandent depuis de diffuser des films
québécois notamment la déesse des
mouches à feu qui sort le 26 février
alors pourquoi pour leur accueil comme
on dit en anglais je joue est le film
là-haut moment qu'on nous a dit de
fermer les cinémas 2 j'ai toujours joué
les films québécois pour les
distributeurs québécois qui me
connaissent ils savent que sur le succès
de certains de leur film dépeint bien
sûr des faits que le cinéma vous disons
jouent leurs films dans l'es9 complexe
qu'on a
il ya des films qui n'ont jamais eu
lalalala nombre de sorties d'écran qui
ont eu comme nous on a fait grâce à
cinémas guzzo donc on a toujours la
cuisse cinéma québécois et on va
continuer à le faire et madame pintal si
on vous dit on trouve la prochaine
annonce on trouve vous rouvrez quand
êtes-vous prêt est ce que ça vaut la
peine je sais pas moi 25 ou à 50 % de
capacité ont pu quand même parce qu'on a
des programmations qui ont été adaptés à
des jauges réduite
nous on serait prêt à ouvrir à l'animal
par exemple parce qu'on un spectacle qui
est prévu en salles en plus de la
webdiffusion maintenant l'aide de l'état
actuel pour les salles de théâtre les
salles de diffusion
c'est extrêmement précieux parce qu'il
ya une prise en charge d'une partie des
billets qui sont invendus ça nous permet
de faire travailler des artistes des
artisans des concepteurs est de garder
ce lien entre le public et des artistes
donc nous on est prêts maintenant je
pense c'est pas juste une question
politique là en ce moment selon on parle
on parle de la santé publique et la
santé à tous les niveaux alors c'est le
bien public dont on parle monsieur lebon
en est très conscient je pense que
monsieur guzzo vous en êtes aussi très
conscient et le terrain peut jouer un
rôle très actif dans le dans le maintien
de ce bien public message entendu
lorraine pintal et vincent guzzo merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir